this is a scale of a person so you can
kind of get a sense of how big this
thing is it's encircled by hundreds of
cypress trees just look at the scale of
this thing it's a 150 meter tall sphere
taller than the gray pyramids in order
for you to reach the inside you need to
walk into this long tunnel you're
walking for almost 150 meters in the
darkness the more you walk you feel
yourself getting farther and farther and
farther from reality once you reach the
end you're in this Grand concrete sphere
you feel this sense of release and
you're inspired by the magnitude of the
space it's designed so that if it's day
outside light pierces through these
holes in the vaulting which creates the
illusion of stars in the night sky
although this building would never get
built I think we'll lay created poetry
through his architecture and he really
expressed what it means to be a human in
this world